[Music]
hi joanne
hi martin
you're a product manager focusing on
serverless security right
yes
great because i have some developer
questions for you about software supply
chain security
great to hear and it's one of my
favorite topics
[Music]
so xiaowen i hear from developers who
are worried that they might be
vulnerable to software supply chain
attacks in the recent solarwinds attack
the attacker compromised the build
platform
and in the code curve attack the
attacker uploaded an artifact that was
not built by the cicd system
how can i protect my system
well martin it's a complex problem and
we want to help developers navigate it
one thing you can do today is to use
binary authorization to make sure that
only approved builds can get deployed to
google kubernetes engine or cloud run in
your project
great because i have a cloud run service
here that i'd like to secure so that no
one can bypass my csed pipeline can you
walk me through it
sure and i know that you use cloud build
for your cicd pipeline so let's first
enable binary authorization on your
project
go to the cloud console
and click the hamburger menu
then select security and binary
authorization
click enable to turn on the api
now let's deploy your cloud run service
again
okay doing so now this will also take a
minute and now that it's been deployed
let's go back to binary authorization
and click attesters
you will see that in a tester has been
automatically created
from now on this attester will
cryptographically sign every build done
in cloud build so we know where it comes
from
the sign attestation includes provenance
information such as the source code that
it was built from and the commands used
to build it
ah and what will we do with this a
tester
good question if we go back to the
policy tab
we see that there is a default policy
here that allows all images to be
deployed
let's update this policy to require that
all builds must be signed by that a
tester before they can be deployed and
in other words all builds must come from
your cloud build pipeline
click edit policy
select require attestations
click add a testers
and in the at tester name box you can
select built by cloud build in the drop
down then click to add this a tester
click save
policy
now let's review the policy again and
confirm that we're requiring images to
be approved by this attester meaning
that all images must come from cloud
build
ah okay is this policy now being
enforced on my service
not just yet
right now any authenticated user with
the right iem permissions can still
deploy images containers regardless of
where they were built
how do i lock that down
let's go back to your cloud run service
and click the details tab
where it says binary authorization click
enable
now the policy is guarding this service
from containers built outside your
project
i feel better now if i try to deploy a
container that wasn't built by cloud
build in this project uh will the system
refuse to deploy it
yeah i try it out
okay i will go here to cloud run i
happen to know that google provides a
sample container for testing
i don't know how that container was
built but i do know that it wasn't built
by cloud build in my project
let's try to deploy it
and it looks like the deployment failed
perfect just what i want containers
built in my project can be deployed but
not containers built by others
now what if i forget to turn on binary
authorization for my service is there a
way to make sure that binary
authorization protects all the services
in my project yes glad you asked
we support an organization policy for
binary authorization let's go turn that
on
click the hamburger menu
and iam and admin
then organization policies
select allowed binary authorization
policies for cloud run
then click edit
and let's customize this policy and add
a rule that allows the default policy
click done then save
this will take effect within a few
minutes
oh that was also easy
yeah and this protects against attackers
but it also helps you ensure that your
builds are consistent and that no one in
your organization accidentally deploys
containers built on their laptops or on
other places
i like that
now we've plugged one hole here and
viewers should be able to try this at
home pretty easily if they set this up
today the projects would be a little bit
safer
but sean what is the bigger picture here
how can an organization get up to speed
on software supply chain security
overall
great question google and the broader
community have launched a website called
supply chain levels for software
artifacts
oh that's a mouthful
it's abbreviated to slsa which is
pronounced salsa and the website is at
salsa.dev on that website you can learn
about a framework for assessing the
security of your supply chain and
gradually increasing that security level
we welcome everyone to work with us to
level up the supply chain security for
the whole software ecosystem
and in fact what we did together today
with cloud build and binary
authorization already meets quite a few
of those requirements
excellent thank you for joining me
xiaowen you're welcome
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have questions for xiaowenn or me
about binary authorization or feedback
on this episode post them in the
comments
also please let us know what other
serverless topics you'd like to hear
about on the show bye for now
[Music]